on enquête sur des disparitions
certaines récentes d'autres qui remonte
à plusieurs années
oui
le mode opératoire est troublant j'étais
au groupe des disparitions avant au rio
all on étudiait des enquêtes à l'école
de police sont déjà bonnes pour les
archives
ouais tu fais partie des légendes je
peux pas continuer à couvrir
peu importe réputation dit moi je crois
que quand il se met à bouger c'est le
déclic pour la tumeur alors pour qui il
laisse le bonhomme de neige faire des
bonhommes de neige découper des trucs en
petits morceaux
c'est ce que font les enfants pour cris
de l'ordre on vient d'avoir un appel
une autre femme a disparu
a reçu un avis de recherche qui a
disparu sylvia 20 personnes ces mois-ci
bio personnes pourquoi quelqu'un
signalerait votre disparition
il a signalé sa disparition
ensuite il a tué par le monde tout ça ne
doit filtrer
[Musique]
c'est un suicide point final vous êtes
sûr qu'il était seul
ou et catherine j'ai reçu ça c'est entre
lui et moi ils nous observent depuis le
début et nous balade
vous pouviez les sauver vous aimez
[Musique]
je vous ai donné toutes les pieds